in darlington one in seven households is
already in fuel poverty nervous about
what winter may bring
with energy bills seemingly unstoppable
voters who wore back to the
conservatives at the last election want
concrete assurances from the leadership
candidates before they'll do so again
i'd like to hear them say what they're
going to do to help the people that are
really going to struggle to pay their
energy bills they have no idea how the
working
man what he has to do what he has to pay
and how they live
there's no idea because they've never
done it
ahead of tonight's hustings at the
town's hippodrome these residents won't
get a vote in the contest and were split
on who would offer the best solutions he
doesn't live in the real world he's
married to a billionaire he doesn't have
to worry about energy prices liz trusts
i think she's living in cold club kit
with lance and matching fire will be out
this mess and we can't i don't think it
matters who we vote for because i think
they're all doing such a poor job we're
all on the same side
liz trust campaigning in huddersfield
today has upset some in her party by
saying she wants tax cuts not handouts
what i'm talking about is enabling
people to keep more money in their own
pockets what i don't believe in
is taxing people to the highest level in
70 years and then giving them their own
money back
we are conservatives we believe in low
taxes and what i'm not going to do is
announce the next budget uh in advance
of course we'll need to deal with the
circumstances as they arise
rival rishi sunak has been meeting party
members across the north of england his
supporters say tax cuts would lose them
the next election and direct payments
should be offered instead you've called
it an electoral suicide note in an
article this morning why is that i think
this has been very clear she doesn't
want what she's called extra handouts
and i think we understand that but in
extraordinary times i think direct
payments will be the only way to see the
most vulnerable through this very very
difficult winter that we see coming up
before us
our current prime minister handing out
awards to volunteers in downing street
today alluded to the cost of living are
you being given given free
food and drink i said and certainly i
hope you are fantastic
it will savor it because it doesn't
happen very often
in the in the in these in these
difficult uh uh financial times people
are feeling the squeeze
he assured those attending that his
successor would have decisions about
winter support at the top of their
entree tamara cohen sky news